One Tree Hill star hilarie Burton claims
Ben Affleck once roped her on camera and
he wraps his arm around me and comes
every tweaks my last boom on Tuesday the
Oscar winner tweeted that he was quote
saddened and angered by the allegations
of sexual harassment against Harvey
Weinstein adding that the movie moguls
reported behavior was quote completely
unacceptable just hours later Burton a
former host on TRL spoke out against
Affleck claiming he once touched her
inappropriately the 35 year old actress
made the allegation on Twitter when a
fan suggested Affleck should have quote
kept quiet and another recalled quote he
also grabbed Hilary Burton's breasts on
TRL once everyone forgot though Burton
who is currently expecting her second
child with husband Jeffrey Dean Morgan
bluntly responded quote I didn't forget
adding I was a kid the moment in
question allegedly occurred in 2003 when
Burton was interviewing the a-list actor
you're always like I'm just so nice to
you and was later discussed in a TRL
outtakes episode
I don't knows like a good tweak edge
here and there
I'd rather have a high-five on Tuesday
Burton tweeted quote I had to laugh back
then so I wouldn't cry and shared part
of the video on Twitter house every week
smile older on wednesday affleck
responded on Twitter writing quote I
acted inappropriately toward miss Burton
and I sincerely apologize
[Music]
you